hi there this is steve kaufman i'm the
president of link
i speak 11 languages and i have my ideas
on how you learn languages and i'm going
to tell you what the secrets are and how
you get the most out of link
the number one principle in language
learning is to enjoy it
if you're interested in what you're
listening to and reading if you're
interested in the language if you're
having fun you're going to learn
it is not necessary to do grammar drills
it's not necessary to understand grammar
explanations
uh it's not that useful to spend a lot
of time on vocabulary drills
i don't even believe that much in
space repetition systems
because i like to spend my time
with enjoyable content
listening and reading
and for it to be enjoyable it has to be
on something that i find interesting and
it has to be just a little bit difficult
for me but not too difficult
and so the main thing you have to do at
link
or one other thing i should say is you
don't have to speak a lot in order to
learn if you have the chance to speak
speak but mostly you need to listen and
read and get the language into your
brain and the brain will pick it up
but you can do things to help and those
are the things that we do at link
not only can you select content of
interest
but we always have the audio and the
text there
uh
we help you save words and phrases so
that you can start to notice them better
that then generates a lot of
highlighting on the screen a whole bunch
of functionality you can talk to other
members who are native speakers of the
language you're learning you can write
and have it corrected there's a lot of
stuff you can do but the main thing is
remember you've got to enjoy it and
mostly you listen and read because you
can do that wherever you are and it
needn't cost you
anything to do it so
that's basically what i have to say get
on the link
take the trouble to figure out how the
system works and enjoy yourselves